[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance Trump's self-serving wasteful
exploitation already L conceived plan to
travel to Texas in the middle of the
nightmare there was beneath contempt
but the tone-deafness the
disconnectedness the cruelty the
inhumanity of trumps response to the
devastation in Houston and the entire
area did not begin with this like the
terror of the rising floodwaters
themselves it built silently but not
slowly fatally but not obviously as all
of us in this country hoped against hope
that the next day would bring better
news of disastrous prophecies
unfulfilled and worst expectations
ameliorated by good fortune no as first
the wind and then the rain and then the
floods tore into the fourth largest city
in the nation
it became frightening ly and numbing ly
clear that the man occupying the office
of President of the United States has no
human empathy to give no understanding
of tragedy no concern for the lives of
anybody in this nation except those he
knows personally and probably not even
all of those this individual is not by
any understanding any of us have had
instinctually or by experience a leader
of a nation this individual is not by
any understanding any of us have had
instinctually or by experience capable
of comfort nor inspiration nor solace
this individual is not by any
understanding any of us have had
instinctually or by experience a human
being the utter blindness and deafness
to human suffering he is now exhibited
did not begin with these newest words
and in actions we first saw it pushing
its way forward indeed like a rising
tide on Friday night headed to Camp
David for a brief vacation to recover
from his last vacation he was asked mr.
president do you have a message for the
people of Texas good luck to everybody
he said pumping his fist like he was a
fan at a football game they're going to
be safe good luck to everybody good luck
that nightfall came the directive to
initiate banning the transgendered from
the military and then the
our pail pardon and only then the
signing of a disaster Proclamation
Saturday morning a mindless retweet of
the head of FEMA telling him to be safe
not even mustering the kind of throwaway
line that good luck to everybody that he
had mumbled the previous evening and
then the first true indicator of how
little Donald Trump understood of the
risks to Houston the calamity in Houston
the necessity for a president to speak
with concern and empathy to the citizens
of this country who are in harm's way
Trump's first tweet on Sunday morning
his first thought an advertisement for a
book by an RPO like abuser of the law
for Milwaukee the infamous sheriff Clark
a promotional tweet for a book and then
a Houston tweet but not about the
residents just boasting about the
government and the quote thousands
rescued then many people are now saying
tweet again not about the victims but
about the quote great talent on the
ground as if all this were a pitch to
sell enrollments in Texas at Trump
University then a tweet about his plans
to go to Houston not the community not
the victims him his plans and then and
his mind wanders off I will also be
going to a wonderful state Missouri that
I won by a lot in 16 boasting again
about the election and then gibberish
Dems CM is opposed to big tax cuts
Republican will win s and now back to
Houston Wow now experts are calling
Harvey a once in 500 year flood
exclamation point a WoW and an
exclamation point as if the magnitude of
the disaster were something positive or
something for which he deserved credit
and here Donald Trump revealed that the
destruction in Houston was just a
temporary distraction from the distorted
world that exists only in his own mind
19 minutes after the crazy Wow 500 year
flood exclamation point tweet with
Mexico being one of the highest crime
nations in the world we must have the
wall
Mexico will pay for it through
reimbursement / other we're back to the
wall while a city is drowning a city
whose population is more than one-third
Hispanic whose population is more than
one-quarter of Mexican heritage he must
go back to building a wall to keep
people who look like them out of this
country and to disparage the ancestral
home of so many of the victims as quote
one of the highest crime nations in the
world and seven minutes after that tweet
back to Houston hardly a tweet about
NAFTA and Mexico there with highway so
submerged in Houston that the overhead
exit signs are nearly underwater Trump
is prioritizing NAFTA on Monday morning
no new comment from Trump himself merely
retweets starting with Houston FEMA
prayers even know starting with
criticism of the Washington Post and
then criticism of Barack Obama as if the
flooding had ended overnight it is
difficult to recollect this now but well
into the Year 2005 the presidency of
George W Bush was largely seen as a
positive one and then came Hurricane
Katrina and an administration response
that was little and late in which
wreaked of inadequacy and horrific allah
bad planning and echoed with heck of a
job brownie and the head of homeland
security mistakenly calling louisiana a
city and the sudden almost simultaneous
realization in this country that
president bush's sympathy and empathy
for his fellow americans was bluntly a
little less than it needed to be but
look into the soul of a president like
trump who has the black swirling waters
engulf the nation's fourth largest city
could envision only the government
workers and the safety of the FEMA
director and who decided it was all safe
and sound and he needed to get there and
take credit for it while the getting was
good and who woke up Sunday morning
thinking not about how many of the
citizens he swore to protect were dead
but how he could help a man like Sheriff
David Clarke sell his goddamned
book and who went from seeming
excitement over a 500 year flood to 9
minutes later once again trying to shove
down the throats of this society of
immigrants this damned wall to keep out
the brown people and underscored by his
newest tone deafness the startling
realization comes quickly quietly but
still terrifyingly look into the soul of
Donald Trump and what you will see is
there is no soul resist remove peace